êtes vous toujours demander quel chien
sur les votes youtube a préféré s'il
était un chien
cette phrase est très mal tourner ne
vous en faites pas car vous n'êtes pas
seul et apparemment la plus grosse
entreprise du monde a eu la même idée
que moi donc pour n'être qu'un chien
prenait toujours d'hui on va savoir qui
et quel chien ou commence direct avec ma
gueule voilà on sait déjà que ça va être
le chihuahua va pas se mentir but et
cette photo c'est parfait au 1 2 tce
faire d' un [ __ ] de berger hollandais
mon gars il vient des pays-bas
il fait 30 kg c'est à dire que moi en
tant qu'humain je fais aussi 30 kg je
suis très heureux parce que le berger
hollandais ce et cm en héberger voilà en
fait jour ça ok ces parties antoine
daniel jean ou quel chien et huard
hotfile parade dans quelques mois il a
l'air agressif en douane adyal il aime
sa femme il est protecteur il a des gros
saut et il est très musclé c'est faux
alors écoutez on va taper antoine daniel
biceps attention antoine ne nous ment
pas oh [ __ ] de dieu
bodiot toi mais il est trop fort et si
on prend cette image là là ça demande un
[ __ ] de chiens csu aucun chien trouvé
ta trouve la classe antoine hockey
cyprien aller à il est avide et têtu à
vide et et husta bon partenaire pour
faire du jogging
il est amical c'est vrai c'est vrai
qu'ils courent il a fait fondre la
graisse on court en sus prix en gros ça
vous est beaucoup trop fort là il ya un
complot illuminati juin du grenier
inuktitut et un golden retriever attend
est carrément style et il entend bien
avec tout le monde il est fort et actif
et il est doux quand il le faut un il
est fort ce joueur du grenier l'effort a
par contre par contre si tu es un double
rennes c'est à dire linverse de fred il
a l'instinct protecteur il est
intelligent il est courageux c'est seb
une du grenier
ok norman normal ça va nous mettre
moutons tournant matin à grammont
changer la taille norman à cette
virilité qui se ferait tout cela allait
à la salade viril assez bon j'ai trouvé
le vrai but à la normal j'aurais
tellement liste de m moutons j'aimerais
aucun chien trouvé bastia ce que je dis
c'est pas cher c'est un mouton un
rottweiler il adore sa famille les
protecteurs il est massif et il est très
musclé to you tube game est un
rottweiler quoi bomber steak je vais
trouver une photo où c'est à dire un
chiot à c'est mon but dans la vie
mouton ah ah c'est pas un montage bon
passons aux chiennes
on dit qu'elle chienne études c'est
terrible y a rien de mal penser là
dedans attention ne sait pas sous peu
d'un chien en disant plus à temps je
crois que andy un chien qui est vraiment
un show chaud microsoft
attends c'est abusé ena thoune a tous
hâte en méditation roissy jeudi n'a tout
un nom ça dit un coq pas pareil il adore
sortir elle a besoin d'être beaucoup
diriger les athlétiques
non on a tous fait des siennes comme ça
voici plus tard il insiste un shetland
chip de gao tué ceux ci n'a tout à temps
cette année beaupoil 1 watt en la salle
à mettre un chien et ignoble [ __ ] mais
même quand je vois une photo et qui
tissent inspecté un cocker la touche on
peut on peut la a et tailles sont moches
ces chiens c'est quoi je suis désolé
pour tous ceux qui ont un chien comme ça
ah mais oui c'est comme une sorte de
robe la [ __ ] ils sont exceptionnels tu
passes ta vie allez bon ok il ya une
cafetière et eu un labrador retriever oh
c'est pas mal un corps fort et musclé
intelligent et waterproof
ok ça passe ok jumbo savoir quel chien
tu serais tu serais 1 2 tce perdre wade
comme ton père c'est cool hein ok shia
labeouf c'est le monde nous dire la
vérité quel chien et eu un border collie
au lumignons c'est un bon chien rien je
tente un truc
jean dujardin quel chien qu un quota
mais on n'en peut plus de ce golden
retriever tuer le un berger allemand
c'est bien ce double auquel doit guette
eut tué le staffordshire bull terrier
j'en suis carrément vénère comme un
chien c'est carrément vilain comme chien
jeunes doivent supporter tout mignon
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal c'est mignon
dans la parc microsoft exemple des
illuminati si j'ai raison attention même
si c'est les mêmes chiens qui a dans ce
clip
microsoft illuminatis ok qu'un chien
serait les singes question la plus
connue du monde des bergers allemands on
apprend des choses
bâtir c'est quoi ce chien mais qu on
dirait françois hollande mon gars [ __ ]
on découvre tellement de choses
aujourd'hui aller foucault ne ment pas
aux us qui abrutit gare vers la terre un
peu moins chanceux d'un coup à brouter
attend c'est tous les chiens font qu'au
hockey booba quelle sorte de chien et
tulle et mignot à l'intérieur dubaï
quelqu'un de doux de soyaux regardez
même quand il fait ainsi d'huile un
hoquet cachin et pitbull un berger
hollandais on est déçu on est déçu on
voulait tout ce qui est marqué pitbull à
johnny depp ce chien mais cette chaise
luminati ne monte pas mais non mec c'est
pas possible [ __ ] effet quelque chose